hey guys I'm Ryan right Taylor Bradley
this one's a challenge try not to laugh
and it's titled impossible challenge
challenge accept challenge accepted
this will be legend wait for it dary
yeah Neil Patrick oh yeah okay
interior crocodile alligator I drop a
several movies
I believe
oh you touch my tralala knighting
ding-dong
the impressive
go don't look up don't look up go show
this shimmer day I'm Scott
glee
today the masturbator what okay got you
there huh
$10 Islam know what I was expecting him
to say the Gandalf ones the one that
really got me I mean the cat one got me
the first time it came on but before I
got really disturbing yeah mario's what
was that I don't know they were remix in
the showers kind of [ __ ] weird it was
so loud obnoxious I know it was like
immature it was like a fourth bedroom
like haha front of her they were a Jew
is I'm not it was a Lala not LaHood I
was really strange it was really strange
there wasn't that much in it that
actually made me want to laugh yeah
surprisingly I'm very beginning I was
like oh this is gonna be good cuz they
had all these from that 70s show yeah
and that was that was already making me
feel like I was gonna chuckle and then I
was like I'm not gonna be able to do
this and then about two seconds in after
that I was like oh there's gonna be easy
doesn't long that was long well I've
seen longer now you have big penis yeah
let's not lie to your subscribers I wish
I had sorry guys he's lying
yeah that wasn't that funny I was a
little disappointed yeah it's an
impossible not to laugh but that was
more like randomly creepy at times than
anything else yeah it made me feel like
like the Internet is a weird place that
sometimes has a lot of stuff that
deserves to just be hidden away in the
sock drawer of the internet that should
never be looked at
I feel like I got sexually taken
advantage of I'm sorry yeah it does feel
like I feel like I have been like abused
in some way I'm very sorry I wish I
couldn't make it off like that yeah so I
just don't watch that video again
laughing in my abuse yes anyway guys um
thanks for setting me that uh and then
for sitting through the whole video of
us looking at that yeah if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real
rejects you could follow tailors channel
the tailor Bradley Channel that's what I
call it I like it the tailor Bradley
Channel a lot of fun stuff on their
poems monologues song songs acapella
don't forget the songs and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram or
Twitter where if we get product
placement with enough followers we will
endorse anything really like like
highlighters highlighters are great you
know what I do with highlighters
highlight I highlight the spots on my
girlfriend's body that she really likes
to be touched at that's so romantic
yeah yeah it's all over her vagina is
that it isn't that the only place woman
I'd really touch it seems not creating
occasional nipple
I wanted a mark her butthole that she
was like no well that's it's her choice
where she must be marked this was such a
romantic idea and then you just just
made it Balazs a is that a type of
position no I'm sorry to your girlfriend
don't worry she doesn't watch these
videos she really does